this is Germany in the 1980s before the
Berlin Wall came down still fractured in
two between two World superpowers and
this is the map of nuclear power plants
that powered the country the 1980s was
an eventful time period for this
recovering Nation Chernobyl located here
just north of Kiev exploded showering
Europe in radioactive material the
severity of this incident can be hard to
grasp in hindsight iodine tablets were
distributed across Europe an emergency
preventative medicine to ensure the
thyroid gland is saturated in
non-radioactive iodine preventing it
from absorbing the radioactive iodine
present in nuclear fallout where it
could fester and cause cancer they
Fallout from Chernobyl spread on
Westerly winds across Europe and the
News spread faster the people of Europe
were afraid local people received 7.4
milligrams an hour of radiation
radioactive cesium is recycling in the
Moss
because they are thinking all days about
this radiation disorderation and nothing
more the Chernobyl disaster could reap a
bitter Harvest for the peasant farmers
of Poland's far north east if the worst
has already happened the first cases of
leukemia should be appearing now
Chernobyl was given the highest ranking
on the international nuclear event scale
A7 a major accident with a large release
of radioactive materials
or in less technical terms Europe was
crop dusted in cancer dust this event
understandably put a big dent into the
support of nuclear energy across the
world but this wasn't the Genesis of the
anti-nuclear movement in Germany in 1975
30 000 protesters occupied the
construction site of a new nuclear power
plant in Southwestern Germany on the
border with France in 1979 seven years
before Chernobyl two hundred thousand
protesters took to the streets of
Germany after the three-mile island
nuclear disaster in the United States
the anti-nuclear movement in Germany was
a Grassroots movement led by the people
and driven by fears of the very real
danger nuclear energy poses there was a
tremendous amount of political pressure
to begin phasing out these plants and
these protests led directly to the
creation of Germany's green parody in
the Chernobyl accident in 1986 simply
strengthened the support for the Green's
political ideology to phase out nuclear
energy completely in 1998 the green
parody came into power for the first
time and the true end of nuclear power
in Germany was all but secured it was
decided that no new nuclear power
generators would be built in the country
from then forward and in 2002 a law
Banning new nuclear energy was passed
with two nuclear power plants being
taken off prematurely in Germany soon
after
Angela Merkel and her opposition party
the CDU called these deactivations
destruction of National Property however
in the wake of the Fukushima disaster
even merkel's opposition to the
anti-nuclear movement began to falter
Fukushima is the only other incident in
the history of nuclear power that was
ranked on par with Chernobyl receiving
the highest ranking possible due to its
impact on the environment and the people
of Japan
the green party's power in Germany was
now at an all-time high winning control
in influential and powerful states in
the south of Germany for the first time
anti-nuclear movement was too large a
political football or perhaps nuclear
football to ignore and merkel's CDU
parody joined the anti-nuclear movement
nuclear energy had lost this war and the
final power plants in Germany began to
flicker out
on April 15 2023 the final nuclear power
plant was shut down Holding On Through
the energy crisis caused by Russia's
invasion of Ukraine it finally met its
planned end
the images of protesters celebrating the
end of their 50-year war on nuclear
energy were met with anger and disgust
by pro-nuclear activists online
mirroring merkel's destruction of
National Property outrage in the early
2000s
how could you celebrate something that's
so clearly harms Germany's goals of
clean energy shutting its nuclear
facilities has caused Germany to be far
more dependent on fossil fuels than its
neighbor France
this is what a typical day in France
looks like base load is provided by
nuclear energy providing 65 to 75
percent of the country's power depending
on the time of day
wind solar and hydro play their part 2
with a small amount of flexible gas
powered plants available to quickly ramp
up when called upon releasing just 30 to
40 grams of carbon dioxide per kilowatt
hour generated
France isn't a group of few an
industrial giant energy independent not
reliant on Foreign imports of fossil
fuels and not just powering its own
country on low carbon energy it also
supports its own economy by exporting
massive quantities of this power to its
neighbors through high voltage
interconnections a rare example of a
country with few fossil fuel resources
of its own becoming an energy exporter
Germany couldn't be any more different
Germany emits around 440 grams of carbon
dioxide per kilowatt hour generated due
to the fact that 20 to 25 percent of
Germany's power comes from the
environmentally disastrous coal with a
further 10 to 15 percent coming from gas
with the remaining power coming from
wind solar and biomass
while Germany does receive a large
percentage of its power from Renewables
without adequate energy storage or a
nuclear based load the country has
become extremely dependent on fossil
fuels this dependence became all the
more apparent As Natural Gas imports
from Russia were cut off causing
electricity prices to Skyrocket across
Europe
this feels like a blatant own goal a
10-fold increase in carbon emissions
Germans aren't ignorant of the damage
coal is having on their environment
either expansions of coal mines have
been protested too and the green parity
of Germany has been under Fire for its
vote of approval for an expansion of an
open pit mine if there's ever been an
icon of industry-driven climate change
it has to be the Colossal bucket
excavators that roamed this mine the
German government has expressed a desire
to phase out Coal Power soon but their
only realistic option to do that
currently is to import even more natural
gas
one thing needs to be acknowledged in
this debate both sides of this argument
ultimately want the same end goal Clean
safe sustainable energy we are on the
same team the disagreement is on what is
considered clean and safe
this exact argument went to the European
Parliament in 2022 where France fought
for EU legislation to label nuclear
energy and natural gas to be labeled
green that second particle seem strange
but natural gas does play a vital role
in expanding Renewables in the absence
of suitable energy storage
that subject needs an entire video to
itself to explain this legislation
divided the European Union with 328
votes four and 278 against the success
of this legislation angered money with
politicians labeling it an odious
greenwashing attempt with macron as
conductor clearly this is a divisive
issue and Greenpeace is currently trying
to soothe the EU over it but this
legislation paves the way for more
countries to emulate what France has
done and invest more money into nuclear
energy while meeting EU mandated
sustainable energy targets
France on the surface feels like the
gold standard of climate policy but
let's take a deeper look at how this
came to be and the challenges facing
France in maintaining this energy policy
for that we need to rewind 50 years
[Music]
foreign
Egyptian and Syrian forces have launched
a surprise attack on Israel on the
Jewish holiday of Yom Kippur in an
attempt to recapture land on the Sinai
Peninsula taken from Egypt in 1967
during the Six-Day War Western allies of
Israel rushed to support their
counter-offensive and in retaliation the
union of Arab oil exporters embargoed
exports to these countries causing oil
prices worldwide to Skyrocket despite
France not being a target of these
embargos it was a wake-up call for the
powerful country with few energy
resources of its own its economy was
extremely vulnerable to outside
manipulation nuclear energy was the
answer and from 1974 onwards nuclear
energy capacity rapidly grew
over the course of 23 years France
increased its nuclear capacity at an
impressive race building 56 reactors in
19 different locations however new
builds stopped abruptly in the wake of
Chernobyl with only two new reactors
beginning Construction in the aftermath
of This Disaster Chavez 1 and 2 taking
Ace to nine years to complete they came
online in 1997 and 1999. these are the
youngest nuclear power plants in France
24 and 26 years old
the oldest nuclear reactor currently is
the boujee 2 reactor brought online in
1978 it is now 45 years old
its older sibling boujee1 began
operation in 1972 and was decommissioned
in 1994. this was an obsolete design
graphite moderated and cooled with
carbon dioxide it needed to be
decommissioned for safety reasons
nuclear power plants typically have life
expectancies between 20 and 40 years but
poses a problem to the French national
grid and the European Grid at large I
listed every nuclear power reactor in
France on this Excel sheet and I was
honestly shocked when I hit the
averaging function the average age of
nuclear reactors in France is now 39
years old
and these aging reactors are beginning
to cause some major headaches in France
in 2022 in the midst of an energy crisis
triggered by Russia's invasion of
Ukraine France's energy utility provider
the EDF was ordered by the country's
nuclear Watchdog to inspect all plants
after a 23 millimeter deep crack was
found in a 27 millimeter thick cooling
pipe which circulates low-level
radioactive cooling water to the reactor
the cracks formed as a result of thermal
fatigue in a weld seam where Heating and
Cooling Cycles caused the pipe to expand
and contract this crack could have
ruptured the pipe at any moment and its
presence raised alarm bells for the
state of nuclear energy in the country
and subsequent cracks were found at
other reactors in the aftermath of these
discoveries nuclear energy output for
the country fell to a 34-year low while
these plants were taken offline for
inspection and repairs
this problem was a result of Decades of
under-investment and mismanagement of
nuclear energy in France and to make
matters worse the technical skills
needed to fix the issue have faded from
existence in France as a result of the
30-year Gap in nuclear energy
Investments and construction
France is now rushing to invest and
support welding schools to bring back
this important skill and they need it
desperately now just as the Yom Kippur
War woke France up to its energy
situation the war in Ukraine and these
power outages are encouraging political
movement
France has begun a frantic reinvestment
cycle into nuclear energy just a few
days after narrowly escaping and ousting
from government through an unsuccessful
no-confidence vote a new nuclear energy
investment plan won a landslide Victory
gaining bipartisan support the plan will
see 56 billion dollars be poured into
building 6 Next Generation epr2 nuclear
reactors
the first generation epr began
Construction in Northwestern France in
2007 over 16 years ago when the average
age of French nuclear reactors was just
21 years old it still hasn't delivered
any power and is nearly five times over
budget at 13.2 billion dollars a fair
cry from the three billion dollars and
eight-year construction time originally
quoted
the second generation design has been
specifically redesigned to address these
cost and construction issues the design
challenge of making these nuclear
reactors safe with all of the knowledge
we've gained from accidents over the
years is immense
this is not an isolated incident this
study states that out of 180 nuclear
power construction projects
175 of them over ran cost estimations
with an average cost 117 percent more
than estimated and taking 64 percent
more time than expected
the latest delay of this new reactor was
due to simple welding issues again when
even your welds require specialized tea
treatments requiring specialized skilled
laborers and stringent safety checks
it's going to cause headaches
the reality is nuclear energy keeps
getting more expensive as new safety
standards are realized with each
accident that occurs while renewable
energy keeps getting cheaper the first
of the six Next Generation epr2 reactors
will not begin construction until May
2027. optimistically they will take
about eight years to construct at which
point the average age of nuclear
reactors in France will be about 49
years old
aging nuclear reactors to say the least
are not ideal posing major reliability
issues as we've already seen but a
potentially disastrous safety hazard too
France is staring down the barrel of
major electrical grid instabilities due
to Decades of under-investment in
nuclear energy nuclear energy when Don
rice is clearly the best solution to
reduce carbon dioxide emissions that we
have right now but the problem is it
frequently isn't done right
so we have to ask ourselves does Germany
have a point where they right to close
these nuclear reactors down or perhaps a
middle ground between France and Germany
is needed slowly ramping down nuclear
energy while developing new renewable
energy resources with the energy storage
needed to create a stable Grid or
perhaps we need to acknowledge the fact
that nuclear energy as it stands is not
viable long term and we need to invest
in future technologies that make it
safer cleaner and cheaper the reactor
still under construction in France as it
stands has a cost of 8 million dollars
per megawatt while wind turbines cost
between one and two million dollars per
megawatt and critically they can be
installed gradually without having to
commit billions to a single project
in a sense wind turbines are modular
smaller cheaper Easy to replace
one future Tech being worked on right
now aims to give nuclear energy this
same Advantage a small modular nuclear
reactors aim to make smaller reactors
that generate less power but can have
additional modules added over time to
increase capacity reducing initial
capital investment making it easier to
replace aging modules and allowing the
reactors to be placed in locations not
suitable for larger traditional power
plants there are several companies
working on these designs right now and
in the next episode of real engineering
we Deep dive into these Technologies
until then you may want to get ahead of
the game I get asked by engineering
students pretty frequently if I have any
advice on how to do well in college I
only really have two bits of advice that
I think is applicable to every person
first get to know your teachers they
want to help you and experienced
well-connected friends or how you get
opportunities in life second get ahead
of your peers
students get a huge amount of time off
in summer and most including myself
wasted it I spent my Summers enjoying my
free time but I'm mostly wasted at
playing computer games and partying
until I struggled to get a job after
college I didn't realize how much time I
had wasted once I got accepted into my
master's program I decided to change how
I approach life I asked the head of the
aeronautical program what the most
difficult subjects were and if I could
get a copy of the text box early he sent
them out and I came into my stability
and control classes ahead of everyone
else it enabled me to help my classmates
and make friends and allowed me to
concentrate on projects when time was
tight in exam season teaching yourself
isn't easy though however I have a
solution to that brilliant an excellent
platform that can help you brush up on
the essentials of engineering it uses
interactive courses that test your
knowledge along the way a platform
designed to teach you difficult subjects
in the most efficient way possible using
visual interactive examples and they
don't impede your progress when you
struggle if you can't figure out an
answer you can open up an in-depth
explanation and move on to the next
section you can try it out for free and
see whether you like it but the first
500 people to sign up with my link will
get 20 off brilliant's annual premium
subscription I would highly recommend
completing every course on the advanced
mathematics syllabus on brilliant every
single one of these will give you an
edge in understanding engineering
Concepts if you aren't comfortable
diving in this deep there is a
mathematics fundamental syllabus that
will get you there second Learn Python
it can help you automate things to make
your life easier and it can be used in a
lot of engineering software I used it in
my master thesis to create plugins for
Abacus an engineering modeling software
for testing designs I struggle to teach
it to myself when I needed it and I wish
I just came into my masters already
knowing it if you've never done any
coding before you can check out their
new course thinking and code which will
help you understand the basics of how
computer programs work then once you've
mastered the basics brilliant has more
advanced python courses too these are
likely the most universally useful
courses to present and future Engineers
but there are plenty of other courses on
brilliant AI data science neural
networks and more you can get access to
that course right now and all of
brilliant's other curated courses too by
clicking the link in the description and
on screen now you can get started for
free and the first 500 people to do so
will get 20 off Brilliance annual
premium subscription